It's starting to look like we
actually got some work done, right?
I told you all the Gulp
work would pay off.
In fact, I have a final piece that would
make a lot more sense now that we have
our first task written down.
Gulp comes with a killer
feature called watch.
Think of it as an automatic trigger
that waits for something to change.
Previously I needed to notify James
every time I wanted him to do some task.
Now I can rely on the watcher
doing it automatically.
Consider what you currently have to do.
If you make any changes to
your sas file right you
need to switch to the terminal,
re enter gob styles, execute it,
switch to the browser and reload.
A proper watcher let's you never
switch to terminal again.